Barbara Bush was a relentless advocate
for her husband was also dedicated to
advancing literacy in the United States
she was born in New York in 1925 the
third of four children the bushes were
married for 73 years longer than any
other president and first lady mrs. Bush
spoke with us two years ago and one of
her last televised interviews you are
one of the most beloved first ladies in
America if not the most no that's not
true I'm the mother of wonderful
children and the wife of the world's
greatest man a modest Barbara Bush was
so popular she surpassed her husband
President George HW Bush in public
opinion polls they met when she was just
16 and married when she was 19 and he
was a 20-year old Navy pilot on home
leave during World War two she often
joked that her success in life came from
marrying well what has kept love alive
humor I fell in love with him
practically at first sight as a young
couple the bushes moved to Texas and
built an oil business they had six
children but their oldest daughter Robin
died of leukemia at the age of three in
1966 George Bush was elected to Congress
and the family headed to Washington DC
one of 29 moves that Barbara Bush
organized during their marriage as first
lady she focused on early childhood
education for preschoolers and adult
literacy for their parents I honestly
believe that if more people could read
write and comprehend we would be that
much closer to solving so many of the
problems that plagued our nation she won
over the American people with her warm
self-mocking charm and speaking of
glamour I want you all to look at me
very carefully
please notice the hair the makeup
designer clothes after the bushes left
the White House they saw two of their
sons carry on the family legacy in
politics Georgia's governor of Texas
before being elected president in 2000
and Jeb as governor of Florida vote for
Jeb in 2016 mrs. Bush campaigned for Jeb
during the GOP presidential primaries
mrs. Bush you've been involved in a lot
of campaigns mm-hmm too many it was just
a few years ago you said no more bushes
in the White House honey I knew you were
gonna bring that up and I said it
because it's such a sacrifice for his
family but now I know he's so needed
that he has to run what do you want the
bush legacy to be I mean you're watching
a camp a children and the grandchildren
at the end of your life you will never
regret not having passed one more test
winning one more verdict or not closing
one more deal you will regret time not
spent with a husband a child a friend or
a parent an incredible life